what's up guys the announcement was just
two days ago the teaser trailer for thor
love and thunder was finally released
and of course one of the big talking
points
was mjolnir wielded by mighty thor
herself jane foster asphalt has released
a version of it and i believe we are the
first in the world to actually get in
our hands to show you what it looks like
and how it works so with that
let's talk about the owner
[Music]
man look at this love and thunder zaki
80s graphics right here
sweet child of mine was playing we can't
play that song due to copyright but you
can play it can't you
she's gotta smile
before we do that though please
subscribe to the channel like this video
helps us out a lot and also we had a
quick message from our sponsor
this video is brought to you by secret
lab here at geek culture we love our
secret lab chairs especially the all-new
2022 titan evo with its revamped 4-way
lumbar system for enhanced back support
if you leather 2.0 isn't your cup of tea
then consider the all-new soft weave
even more soft and breathable than
before the chair comes in more colors
including this lovely frost blue the
titan evo is even magnetized allowing
the head pillow to stick on the headrest
without straps of course there are even
more new features so do check them out
at secretlab.com
alright and with that let's talk about
mjolnir now of course this is the miller
that came out a few years ago the
original from has pulse looks great
quite hefty this one unfortunately
doesn't work anymore it's retired but it
still looks great great for paperweight
however it's all about the cracked
mjolnir how does it feel how does it
sound how does it light up first let's
look at the box
beautiful graphics on the outside of it
let's turn it around right here multiple
languages because has pulse is very
inclusive so pretty much all the
languages you need to have are there and
also inside the instruction manual
inside of it lights up make sounds
alright so the length of it is about
19.18 inches or 48.7 centimeters pretty
much the same as this mule number right
here so a little bit of tv magic without
further ado
we've got mjolnir
look at that
how about that it has a stand holy [ __ ]
wasn't supposed to happen that way
anyway we also got to stand here a
little bit of tv magic times two
the stand looks
exactly the same
as the original except it's got matte
finish inside of it where the original
is polished finish
that is better right right okay but
first you want to see comparisons to the
original mjolnir and to the mighty thor
milner
looking at it right now
i would say almost exactly the same
exactly but there are some subtle
differences let's talk about that right
now first off let's talk about the
handles now this is a really nice
texture to it and but this obviously is
a little bit darker more richer brown on
the mighty thor milner and then of
course the leather strap or faux leather
i don't know what it is maybe there's no
cows that were sacrificed for this um is
a little bit darker than the original
mjorno but you know this has been hd
thor's been using this for quite some
time maybe this is a little bit newer
who knows but if we look around the side
around the design of this
real quick you like that movement that
was pretty cool right uh we have the
same scribes that are on all sides of
each of the uh
uh muners here so it's the same exact
design
even on the top as well
but it really does come down to
the cracks around it that's gonna be the
big difference now in terms of weight
this is a big difference this is pretty
substantial in weight i don't know the
exact weight we don't have a scale here
you do you do
we have a scale yeah we did it fantastic
zacky i knew we had a scale so we're
going to weigh the original meow right
now
on the scale zeroed out batteries inside
1239
grams
pretty hefty
now we're going to weigh mighty thor's
meal
batteries inside as well
[Music]
so this is
943 grams so a significant difference
between the original mjolnir from a few
years ago and mighty thor's mjolnir as
of today now of course
this could be different materials used
who knows but nonetheless that's the
weight difference okay let's move out
zachy's very famous scale and let's get
back to talking about the design of this
now it does feel really good in the hand
i have to tell you that right now it's
very easy and i think for cosplayers out
there you're gonna enjoy this and even
if you want this in your collection it
feels really good now it is plastic
through and through um
and it feels a little bit hollow inside
but of course there's lighting involved
now to show you where the battery
compartment is this is very interesting
because
unlike the original
where it actually has the battery door
right here at the bottom of it which
does take away from the aesthetics a
little bit i think hasbro has realized
that they can make this a little bit
more inconspicuous
and uh make it look quite unique and
nonetheless the battery door is really
right
here
that's the door
and then you can see where we put the
three double a batteries inside of it
just unscrew it drop in the double-a
batteries and you're good to go pop this
on and it only goes on one way so if it
doesn't go on the one way
press it down
and you're good to go
but
[Music]
and there you see
it's turned on
mjolnir
[Music]
all right baby i'm rocking and rolling
we need some rock music at this point in
time right let's do that we're going to
do a segment here zach i'm thinking
about this just go with me
it's already turned on but we're going
to do this can we turn on the lights a
little bit
you know turn the lights down turn the
lights down
three
two
one
yeah
[Music]
all right
yeah rock on man we gotta do the jane
foster pose right when she wins like
there are jane foster pose
zac i'm thinking
because you're great at putting in some
good music some good rock music right
now
so
the older montage mueller montage baby
[Music]
[Applause]
oh that was fun all right yeah now let's
talk about the sound of mulder now we
can't compare it to the original
unfortunately this uh our model here at
geek culture
doesn't work anymore it's been retired
rest in peace miller you've uh done us
well put you to the side
let's talk about
this meal now we're talking about the
speakers inside a mule now real quick
the speaker hole's right here now
on some of the hasbro pulse products
that we reviewed in the past some of the
sounds have been hit and miss right not
as loud or just didn't sound that great
this is quite loud depending on the
sound profile now there's three sound
profiles inside of this
this let's go through them real quick
[Music]
decent right
you hear the explosion right there
that's pretty loud when you're holding
it next to you
that one's loud number two is really
loud with a thunder crash
[Music]
that's loud
that's pretty awesome right there
it's like he's it's like mueller's just
going through a planet right
[Music]
thunder
yeah man
rock
on whoa
that's there that's the crackle right
there baby that's a crackle okay so
there's about three or four depending i
think there's about three in there but
they sort of merge together but
nonetheless
some sound louder than others but this
is pretty loud so if you're in a room a
quiet room like we're in here right now
in a studio you can really hear this and
the lights will go out then they'll come
back on it'll glow
it looks good especially in lower light
situations so if you're gonna put this
in your display cabinet you know like
this you can see that it's glowing now
i mean in bright lights here in the
studio looks okay but of course if you
want to turn it out
it'll look pretty good and it kind of
gives a little bit of a pulsating
light
really really cool i have to say
so this is a fun
i mean a fun thing to have right if
you're a fan of thor mighty thor this is
a must-have for your collection and of
course we don't know how it was reforged
obviously it's been reforged many times
in the comics but how it's done in love
and thunder we'll find out and of course
does it give jane foster the power is
she you know according to natalie
portman i've seen online
her character has cancer and when she's
mighty thor maybe that helps her out so
so that's essentially it for the mighty
door mule nerd now
there are three thor products out there
there's the original mjolnir which you
can find it online you probably find it
secondhand or from collectors out there
there's the new one that's going to be
coming out very soon then of course
there's my personal favorite
which isn't mjolnir but it's
storm breaker
and this is heavy man this is heavy
and it's pretty badass
this is awesome
but again not everybody will have room
for this
not everybody well we have room here
geek culture well we actually don't but
we make room because we like these kind
of things
but this
is awesome but i will say
the mighty thor milner is louder than
stormbreaker
so if you learn the loudness gotta go
for the
new
but if you like size
you got to go stormbreaker
oh that's heavy so so anyway guys those
are my thoughts on
the new mjolnir mighty thor's mule nerd
let me know your thoughts in the comment
section below can you stop please
yeah these things just keep fingers
going
[Music]
it's raining it's raining mjolnir music
right now i don't know what the hell is
going on here okay can we all really
calm down okay
this is overkill if this little glad
this one stopped otherwise we'll be just
like
all right this button is very sensitive
by the way okay but anyway those are my
thoughts on the new mjolnir the mighty
thor mulder let me know your thoughts in
the comment section below are you
looking to pick this up are you going to
pass
but how excited are you for thor love
and thunder let us know in the comment
section below like always follow us on
facebook subscribe to us on youtube like
this video helps us out a lot be safe
out there and i'll chat to you soon
yeah
[Applause]
yeah baby
you